beaucoup de chagrin et elle s'est
blâmée pour la perte de nous, imaginez bien sûr
que c'est une affaire de chattes,
donc sa Palmilla unipolaire pour avoir aimé la
fille de l'homme sakura Gandhi ne
connaît pas des décennies si sa maison aime la jument un
problème de vida cette fille je ne le fais pas  Je me souviens de l'
avoir vue ivre quand j'étais enfant et je
ne me souviens pas de l'avoir vue, ce dont je me
souviens, c'est qu'on m'a dit que la ligne s'alignait sur
le mur avec d'autres enfants et donc j'étais
aligné et ils m'ont pointé du doigt Matt tu
as un  chat Hong County police he Lord
Omni él vive la she's a gamma a victor
kuzey
a scissor 11 Isha ne pourrais-tu pas faire ça
pour moi cette fille ma mère ne m'a jamais frappé une
fois qu'elle ne m'a jamais frappé si
tu avais été frappé dans des foyers d'accueil ouais je
me souviens  cordons électriques frappés avec
des cordons électriques Matthew n'a pas été agressé
à la maison il a été agressé dans une famille d'accueil
Danielle garçon ouais Kalidas et trouvé à
part panique exogène el khazzani il
partait connaissait la sympathie de KSA je t'ai rencontré
kavika elle Louie et l'adolescence disent
dis moi toi-même  pendant une décennie
una  général elle défauts d'opale tu as eu un
anniversaire
je l'ai fait donne moi un très bon câlin
je me souviens l'avoir ressenti à travers mon corps
je me sens vraiment bien et je
ne sais même pas si tu es censé le faire
c'est la chose la plus triste  -
Une famille d'enfance m'a dit que tu n'étais pas
censé embrasser le perdant des enfants Gila New
Year me vilipende presse e point macho une télé
Olie cantilever a dit Arita IRA
abus de micro c'était des agressions c'est c'est graphique
est dégoûtant j'avais très honte et
me salir le corps ou la peau a rampé et
quand j'ai dit au parent adoptif qui était
mon parent adoptif à ce moment-là, elle
m'a regardé dans les yeux et elle a dit que
voulez-vous que je fasse à ce sujet, j'ai dit à Matthew
quand il grandit
juste obtenir une éducation  entrez dans le
système de placement familial et réparez-le parce
qu'il est
cassé  gamma le résultat ou c'est une
sieste  avati elle va sûrement me manquer très
court-circuitant vas seulement c'est une
saison fidjienne Kelvin para et Pascal Imelda
Mathieu en sécurité chaque saison agriculteur à
Hawaï ou bisous sociaux - allumage nous avons
essayé tout ce que nous avons essayé fils juges
tribunaux et elle elle comparaîtrait devant le tribunal  et
Meyer avait offert lors de l'incident est-elle
dit le mammouth il s'épanouissait dans
cette famille d'accueil que quand j'ai vu qu'il
avait l'air d'un petit garçon très triste ça
m'a brisé le cœur
Mathieu de la visite d'Eduardo est un bon rayon gamma
Yama peut pas de vive  ciseau
et c'est ta cheville crayons un coton bleu
soie madame court-circuiter une meilleure fille
Jean a fondé la protection - Ernest tu
sais que les anciens disent que l'un des actes les plus
violents que tu puisses commettre envers une femme
c'est juste voler ses enfants donc pas de
chef fixe De Palma inácio  Onofre médecin
névrose étiologie SMA ou Manitoba nous
devons faire le film de l'université de la province
s'en aller a dit les puissances alpha alors qu'est-ce
qu'un vrai Emmy pour le RISM la pauvreté se
présente chez vous et je regarde  dans
votre réfrigérateur dans vos placards et si vous
n'avez pas assez de nourriture, vos enfants
vont s'en occuper et une fois qu'ils sont pris en
charge, cela coûte extrêmement cher
plutôt que d'aider simplement une mère avec
cent ou deux cents dollars d'
épicerie et de travail  avec cette maman pour que
vous sachiez terminer vos études ou trouver un emploi
[Musique]
vous savez que le costume semi-mat Honda sur la
console est un feu Je veux vraiment que
vous preniez cette souffrance et que vous la transformiez en
joie et que vous viviez le meilleur pour elle que j'ai apporté
Matthew parce qu'il est spécial qu'il
a eu une vie vraiment difficile et qu'il a
trouvé ce chemin vers la belle vie qu'il a
trouvée en apprenant sur
lui-même, il a découvert qu'en trouvant la
sobriété et en participant à la cérémonie
et en s'entourant de bonnes personnes,
Cora Morgan peut  c'est un tapis tu vois
Amitabha tu Camco dis toi o par génétique
Don Quichotte problème d'un caducée alors
quand tu as été arrêté lutté après que la
LPL t'ai arrêté comment
tu t'es senti pas bien
médecin en colère pas de clé  r préserve l'
organisme e ID lésion Aleph immédiatement
après la vente du permis de jeu vous avez ajouté l'
origine il répète la joue cela me fait du
bien c'est incroyable c'est la meilleure
chose qui soit sa joie de pouvoir
ressentir des vues et un but non seulement avec
dunya Kaaba votre social  mauvaise idée kasi
perd un indice ça toi ces deux trous pour
apprendre à aider les gens à guérir seront
parfaits et donc je fais ça à travers mes
cérémonies et je pourrai le faire à
travers le western aussi donc
Oh nuit sur Dubois mat tu vois plume
Nouveau semi Silverhawks sur le commerce sur la
cérémonie traditionnelle aujourd'hui je vais
commencer un feu sacré pour que ma mère voyage
ou dans un monde spirituel
dojo Aquafina hideo-sama mathieu
prepareforsegue odigo VAR c hudson
elective in certain piéton in a fast
the hosta so I  Je suis allé voir ma famille et
lui ai demandé, ainsi qu'à mon Indien, et ils m'ont dit
ce que vous pensiez que vous étiez définitivement. Je
n'avais aucun sentiment d'identité. Mon identité était d'
être un
enfant adoptif.  y protéger
que ce feu en moi ma fille
ne m'a jamais vu ivre ma fille n'a pas
vu une fête et seulement de toute façon autour d'elle
ivre alors ne faites pas Alita deux téléphones Bobby
pourriez-vous jamais prouvé pourquoi les frais de vasa
qui perçoivent le pedigree Kamsa Maha
vapeur  Josephus la Fuente Polly le cynisme le
potentiel de tout le monde est infini ce
qu'Allah donne une définition les rires je
veux dire je crois en un soutien communautaire je
crois au système familial je crois
au soutien des familles et des communautés
je pense que si c'est investi tu
auras ton hamster
[  Musique]